heyo it's Andrew here and it is a tidy
Tuesday and for this week I believe
we're doing a rap data set where I guess
it comes from the BBC music and it
contains I guess the voting for the best
rappers okay so we're gonna just do the
normal thing and load it in our data set
and I'm not sure what I'm gonna do right
now but I think so I gonna load up the
tidy verse okay so there's two main data
sets and so I basically as the critic
and their top 5 rap songs of I guess of
all time let me check it first yes it's
it's I guess it's like the best the best
rappers they also broke down the results
into one definitive list but also didn't
just publish the best of list they also
publish the complete results in
description of the simple algorithm they
rank the songs so they basically did
some basic point system where first if
you were ranked 1 you got 10 points you
bring second get 8 points and so on and
so forth okay so we got a polls thing
where actually has like the polling
results and then we have was it what's
it called rankings which has just the
overall rankings of that song so juicy
is is ranked 18 times nine of it nine
times it was ranked number one all right
I think we can we can do some things
with the rankings but I think though a
cool thing would be is to look at
I guess the critics and the and the
polls for that especially since each
person is supposed to just name their
five favorite or five best rap songs we
kind of cool to do a recommendation
engine because that's what I've been
doing for my capstone project and I
think a recommendation engine is pretty
easy to implement
especially in our so we're gonna first
do a basic exploratory analysis on this
so what's - uh we'll just count the
titles first and see which ones were
just um in the lit on a critics top five
list the most so juiciness veggie thing
the message these are right the most
popular songs um
additionally I'm curious if there's like
a kind of I got Golden Age of rap so I'm
gonna do just a account of the year okay
and I'm gonna I guess plot it out so GG
plot y equals and so yeah they're kind
of actually is a there there is kind of
a golden to me there's there might be a
Golden Age rap so I'm gonna wanted to
see if I can do something else with it
um so I'm gonna say you Tate I guess
it'd be it was it decade decade equals a
year divided by was it ten so for for it
and then times ten I think that's how it
works
color equals decade oh it's a okay
that's that
and I gotta make this into a factor just
to make sure
so they get along okay yeah so I did
that that's um
and the thing is a I am not that smart
um this is just like a common way to
round things off by like the the decimal
place so it's a common thing that people
using like I guess like sequel and stuff
like that so yeah this is this very
popular to use to like basically cut off
the mod of it so yeah we can see that
there's like a golden age of of decades
right and just to reiterate the entire
thing we can kind of do almost an
aggregated thing of it so we can do we
just pull out the decade boom so I'm
gonna write the Golden Age of rap is the
1990s it's pretty cool
one thing that I think would be
interesting to look at is let's see here
polls we should count just how many
artists like who's the most famous
artist for it for these things so it's
four equals true notorious b.i.g wu-tang
clan jay-z these are all pretty famous
I guess 90s rappers um who definitely
who I would say you definitely peaked in
the 90s obviously Kendrick Lamar and
Kanye West I would say didn't peak in
the 90s especially Kanye West didn't
peak in the 90s and I think Kendrick
Lamar didn't have any songs there okay
so I don't think let me look at it first
okay maybe I'll do a basic distribution
of it so I'll just say a as X x equals
zero y equals and and then just yeah a
boxplot
mmm so some some people are heavily you
know our heavily mentioned and some
people aren't you either only mentioned
it once so just throw a log
transformation of it just to make little
bit easier I don't anything that's very
good
so might just do a uh I might just
filter and is not equal and is greater
than one okay yeah I'm just gonna remove
it and we'll just remove that actually
sometimes when a box walk doesn't work
because it's heavily skewed I'll just do
a geo meant City because it kind of you
can kinda just get it a better few of it
you can see that Oh
most of them are at zero cool another
thing that I think would be will it
would be interesting is like Oh what
about artists who have like today who
are like a very that they're like the
top artists but they're not the top of
the top right so maybe they're mentioned
a lot as like the number five
but the never like the top the like
their songs are never the most favorite
songs right they're only kind of like my
fifth favorite song artists so we're
gonna kind of do this aggregation of it
I gotta go back up and make sure what
rankings okay okay so rankings is like
the actual rankings polls is from the
critics so I'm gonna have to remember
that select artists and N one and two
and three and four five there's
definitely a better way to do that you
say like contained and an artist but I
it's not a big deal okay let's here I
just wanted to make sure there's there's
there's gonna be duplicates yep so
there's gonna be duplicates so I think
we can do uh was a group by artists
summarize is there somewhere all and
then we can say some yes okay so we we
kind of run into a few problems here we
can see that 2pac or Tupac Jesus a
two-block has some features
and we can either leave it in or just
resolve it and I think it depends on
your perspective of I guess how you
should be counting artists like it's
hard because what we're trying to do is
equate an artist and seven artists songs
so we might just remove the features
altogether so that way they're just not
mentioned because it's more of like a
shared thing and we want to look at um
everyone else this is pretty arbitrary
so I'm gonna say STR detect feet oops
it's artists okay in it and so I just
said art so I said us any string that's
in the artist that has a word feature in
it we're gonna remove or we're gonna say
not basically nuts okay so I think that
should resolve everything everything's
good
cool okay um
now let's just plot out cutie-pie yes x
equals I want to see a good let's figure
out what good way to visualize is like
who are the what just do basic filtering
okay so filter or we can do uh top and
n5 n equals okay so Grandmaster Flash
and the Furious Five
jay-z Kendrick Noir oops I'm gonna do a
range boy in five
it's a Kendrick Lamar he's mentioned a
lot as the five actually I got it I got
a better idea
okay so we're gonna do a GD plot and
we're gonna just show n 1 and n 5
go maybe we'll do it GL smooth just to
see if there's any relationship okay
there is like us it's a weighted thing
is there it can find a relationship we
can fit a line into it I don't know if
it's actually an actual relationship or
is just can do is able to fit on line
it's pretty easy if I don't line between
points so how many GM jitter just a
mixture at this point does how many
overlap so there we go we can see how
most of it is centered around okay you
have a few top fives or a few top top
best songs so I'm gonna say rank 5 and
rank 1 songs the majority time you don't
have it in in the say like the upper
right where you have a lot of ranked 5
and wrinkled ends its you just contrary
to a small amount so it's really
extrapolating and we don't really want
this GM smooth function because it's not
really a real real relationship go let's
do uh maybe I cut scale I'm just with a
scale X square root maybe and plus scale
Y square root or maybe a clog 10 I don't
think that's right okay we're not gonna
do that okay so now we actually want to
look at we want to look actually look at
the guys who have who have like let's
just arrange by n1 oops
descending order
right so notorious b.i.g he has the most
like top favorite rank one songs same
with Public Enemy and wu-tang clan oh
they also have a lot of not a lot so I
for example Public Enemy like they have
a lot of favorite songs that are like
ranked one and only one time where their
song was ranked on the bottom okay so
I'm gonna actually do a slice so we're
gonna just grab the first five people
and it right here we're gonna do the
same thing but we're gonna do descending
over for n 5 and now we can kind of look
at it and let's see if there's any
duplicates so Grand Master Grandmaster
Flash he has like the most they have the
most like one the top 5 favorite songs
and also the bottom of it so they have a
lot of top ones and a lot of top fives
which Kendrick Lamar he has a lot of top
ranked fives but not on a rank once
which kind of kind of odd especially
when you see how like the people who
have most ranked fives or the least
favorite of the best are I think a
little bit more recent artist than the
the the best of the best so maybe these
critics are only just kind of like
romanticizing 90s or maybe the nineties
we're just really the best age you never
know so that's just like a basic kind of
an outlook kind of like just a look at
the songs that were actually used or
songs that were considered as the best
songs but what we really want to look at
is up polls for it so we're gonna look
at polls okay um critic country
interesting I wonder if credit country
has anything
do with it so we're gonna do just do a
count critic country okay so most whoa
Germany it's at 45 us is at 306 five
that's interesting
there's actually a decent mixture of it
I would expect way more just like ages
to be completely American centric but
okay so country to is Curtis and Curtis
and so I think we can just ignore
country to I guess what I'm curious
about is I wonder if there's like a
discrepancy of of countries so I wonder
if I Canadian countries like Drake more
than a kupaka whereas like American a
USA critics like like I don't know - I
asked something that someone else so
we're gonna do that we're actually going
to go and count the title so count for
every title we're gonna count the critic
country okay and we'll just filter and
is and does not equal one just to filter
it out a little bit more and then we'll
do a range by title okay okay so most of
it is so I got an idea - so count critic
country and will say the name equals
name equals um song nom so that's like
how many now many nominations that title
get so will say did that song get and
then we'll also add account of just like
critic country I know will add account
where there's the title and that name
will be number of country countries
all right so so 99 til infinity has two
countries and has been nominated um
seven times right in total okay so now
we're going to filter we're number of
we'll say let's see here
filter we're number oops
oh the countries is equal to one right
so and then we'll say filter will say
and critic country just not equal to us
and we see eighty-three of it eighty
three rows so eighty three and we'll say
in row and row and then we'll say
divided by n row of polls so okay we'll
say 15 percent of the hold of the top
songs or voted by only one country so
there's there so there could be like
it's like a a hometown such country bias
is if these critics are saying that
these are the best songs of all time
and these songs only get one vote I
would think that's a little suspicious
okay okay now we're gonna keep on going
and look at let's do uh it's your song
nomination by the country song nom
country right cuz okay yeah cuz cuz then
it's like us it does six times
okay now what I'm curious is let's see
your how can we how can we figure out I
guess the average what I'm trying to
realize oh is there like do countries
vote relatively the same so let's do
which is to a GG part of it so GG plot
and now we can't do it GG plot what's
here I will say filter number of
countries does not equal 1 ok I'm gonna
also say count title count now we can't
do that did that what else can we do
it's a number of countries so most of
the time us is the majority okay I got
an idea
so now we don't need it so we'll say
it's like - will deselect on the number
of countries which I should change to a
better thing then we'll do look up maybe
a pivot wider names from equals critic
country values from equals song nom
country values fill list and we'll say
song nom country equals 0 ok
actually I think it's already uniform
when we let me check it again yeah we're
fine with that
okay we'll just do uh ggplot see what
well I kind of want though is kind of
like a a grouping to see to see how they
they react with each other so I think I
might have to do the pivot wider thing
then GG PI oh wait no I can just do it
uh let's hear I could probably do a
ggplot x equals critic country y equals
song no country and then we'll say and
we'll say a group equals title song
wykel's
okay there you go and I will see what
okay not really what I wanted and I
think this this doesn't really make any
sense for what I'm trying to view so I'm
gonna scratch this entire visualization
and do the oops pivot wider names from
critic country values from song country
now we're just at 52 and I think we can
kind of compare man man I really want to
I think ggplot a yes there there's
definitely a good way to do this I'm
just not sure how I should do it though
uh let's see you you know calm Plus
maybe I do a facet grid or rows equals
bars title bars a critic goals bars
critic country and then cup calls egos
bars critic kind critic country
okay now we'll do yeah maybe I'll get
calls nope okay I don't like any of this
I think this yeah it's fine we kind of
look at the dist let's throw it like
that I'm trying I you know I could spend
like a decent hour time on this but I
don't really need to so we're just gonna
ignore that that's fine the big thing
that works action I look at is is uh is
the actual recommendation for each
critic named so we're gonna do that
first so we're going to do polls I want
to select critic name title rink okay
and the ranking I believe the ranking is
through like if you're ranked 1 Rank 1
is the best right um yes first ring
track so what I'm gonna do is okay for
the recommendation inch and what we're
gonna have to do is process it into a
matrix so what I'm trying to decide is
doing when I evaluate this as our
ratings matrix or a binary matrix and
the reason is technically these ranks do
have sort they could be perceived as
almost stars right where it's a 1 is
essentially a five-star ranking and a 5
is a low a lower star however lower
stars in in the in the context of a
recommendation engine is bad however
these are the top five songs so just
because you get a rank five on a song
means you're just like the fifth
favorite which isn't exactly the same
thing as ranking something
as I as rating something like a movie
like on Netflix so what I'm thinking
about doing is changing this rank and to
basically a binary matrix where you're
basically able to choose five songs and
then those are the five songs and they
have similar basically relatively the
same weight because I want to be able to
have someone rate basically choose five
of their favorite rap songs and there's
a list and I have it recommend some more
like five other songs that you might
want to listen to so that's all we're
gonna do we're gonna say N equals one
I'm gonna remove the rink so what this
is saying is okay all these values they
chose those values right so I can just
do kind of like a really efficient way
of just kind of making a binary matrix
there's probably a better way to do it
but this is the way that I kind of do it
so I'm gonna do a pivot wider names
names from equals title values from and
values fill list and equals zero okay
actually I'm gonna do a range title is
to make it a little cleaner okay so what
it's saying is all the all the names
from this title like all like all the
values from the title will be columns
I'm going to fill up each column with n
which we gave it which was the one and
if you don't have that n so for example
Philip Carosa s-- crocus ORS didn't have
a one 422 twos we're just gonna fill
that with a zero and 7n a like this one
so now we have our binary matrix so
we're gonna call this fine we'll call
this um rap matrix
okay and we're gonna actually a
different package called recommender lab
and what recommend our lab needs is
actually we got to convert our rap
matrix into an actual matrix so as dot
matrix and we're gonna have to convert
it to a binary rating matrix oops
whereas binary rating matrix Matt do you
have a Scottie mare oh there we go
zeros ones right oh yeah I got us I got
deselect a nickname boom and it creates
a matrix so I'm gonna call this rap I'm
actually gonna put this guy right there
and I'll put this guy right there
okay so we create our rap matrix and
then we're gonna have to do it was it an
evaluation scheme so what's cool about
recommender or lab is it a recommender
they have a bunch of like pre-made
function into it and it's actually not
all a lot of functions either so it's a
pretty simple thing they're just
recommender and I guess um and then like
you got to do a schema alright so first
you have to create a scheme we give it
our data so we'll say wrap matrix we
give it a method to some method equals
and there's two main collaborative
filtering methods
there's UCF
and I BCF we're gonna do you VCF first
but I give in equals and we'll say
giving equals for what's going on here
yeah look at it first
I always get confused by the the naming
conventions for use functions data
methods but okay there goes it so this
is the actual like training schema so
we'll call this a training schema
valuation evaluation scheme scheme and
our data is a rap matrix and then we'll
say our method our method will be we'll
just do a split so we'll do like an
80/20 and they say train equals 0.8 and
then we also give we also give it a
given which is like the number of items
are gonna give it and we'll say all
about one so how to do all the one as K
equals mine minus 1 given given equals
minus 1 so we're gonna give it all the
data besides of 1 and you're gonna have
it predicted so for example just if we
will get our what if we look at our
poles we would probably just take out
these first 4 and have it try to predict
times up ok so we have our training
schema right evaluation scheme using all
but one items train split with one time
good ratings na since the binary rating
matrix there's no such thing as a good
rating it's just whether plot or not ok
and then we I think it's the evaluate
right I'm not going crazy you know you
value
evaluate yes so that's this is a thing
that I kind of got I switch them around
with evaluation scheme and evaluate so
now we're gonna train up a UB CF model
so evaluate and then we get it a schema
method which will say method equals EB C
F and once a type equals top and list
top analyst is we're gonna how to
predict a certain amount of times so
we'll say N equals five right so we ran
that model it's gonna look at that and
we'll also do I be CF model and the only
thing that's do to change to IB CF and
we train two models so we can kind of
look at our UV CF model to by doing like
average we can find the average I'm
scores so our TPR is nine percent so
nine percent when trying to predict five
items
nine percent of time it'll actually
reach that that one whole item which is
not it's not great right
like I'm so we'll just put it out yeah
it's not it's not great but it's just a
recommendation engine model it's a
recommendation engine so if you look at
like something like Amazon most that
products they recommend you you don't
actually end up buying or they're not
they're never very accurate because it's
using basically a very fast engine to
predict a to predict an item that's a in
the entire product space so there's
really sacrificing predictive power for
speed well we can also look at our
obviously F model and yes it's what she
do oops we'll evaluate average
have UCF model average so currently our
UB CF model is much better than our IV
CF model however we can also go and I'm
tuned our model so we can actually
establish certain parameters so for u v
CF we have nearest neighbor so I'm gonna
just do a a function for this yeah so
we're gonna say train will say tune
UVC F function and then parameters okay
so we're gonna actually give it also a
schema so schema okay and we should
probably put this first just to make it
look a little bit better grammars so
given our schema we're gonna basically
do what we already did right cuz we're
gonna have it and have it evaluate a UV
CF model with the top analyst with five
predictions
however this time we're gonna give it
our parameters or our we're gonna give
it a list and the parameters for this is
a nearest neighbor what is n n so n N
equals parameters actually will say tune
coop tuned engines and engines and tuned
engines so we have our UV CF model we'll
just do our IBC f-102 in this thing and
IBC out they used K nearest neighbors or
something like that so it's it's just K
equals parameters okay
so we have that and we'll work we'll do
you VCF average yeah and won't say yeah
let's here as that data thing
you vfc Milano will say as table yeah as
table okay so we'll say as table and
then we'll say mutate crammed equals
parameters right and we'll do the same
thing for the IBC F model okay and uh
yeah we'll also say mutate pram cuz
parameters and model equals you PCF
whereas this model will be IV CF okay
okay and then we're gonna just are
buying this these two I'll results okay
bye-bye
clean this a little bit so basically
we're gonna say we're gonna train a
model with these given parameters and
return the average results so that way
we can just kind of do everything the
easy way and not have to repeat all this
code we don't have to do this code over
and over again we can just kind of run
it I think we'll just do I think you can
pipe in to a return so we're gonna do
that okay so let's try it out tune
engines will give it our our what is it
our training schema and our parameters
equals
parameters equals we'll say 10 so you
need to have ten of your nearest critics
boom whenever it turns this primers 10
our TPR is this okay so what if we
actually give it a list 10 we'll say
we'll do a 5 10 and 15 it doesn't it
doesn't work because you can't really
give it a list
however we actually can so we'll say
tune grid equals C 5 10 15 okay and then
we'll actually will say it will stay
tuned grim tune grip tune grid we'll
give it a table and we'll say parameters
equals c1 5 15 so we have our tune grid
okay and then we can just do mutate
results equals map DF dot X is our
parameter parameters and their function
is tuned engines tuned engines and we
give it a I always do tune engines and
we give it a trans oh my got tuned
engines trans us was it schema what do
you call it training schema and we'll
give it our training schema and then
program equals x neighbors incorrect
number of dimensions maybe we'll do a 10
let's try it let's just try and map that
X was it parameters tuned engines
training schema got ax
oh I don't why because we can't have one
three five ten okay well uh nested table
but when we have all of this stuff right
because we have it the given parameters
we actually even need to have add this
parameter function so I'm gonna probably
delete that I'm gonna do it this seems
like a lot of work okay so this time
we're do three five ten fifteen twenty
twenty-five and we'll say history
boom so now we're kind of doing a grid
search for the best nearest neighbor it
trains really fast because it's really
just finding the distances and it
already has it as a matrix so it's
pretty easy to actually look at okay so
we're gonna evaluate that results
we're GT plot it out
y equals we're gonna just go for every
parameter we're gonna look at the TPR
and we're gonna have the color equals to
the model and let's find the dream calm
Phil was it nudge isn't nudge x equals
true uh how do I do that again I'm gonna
go nudge chart gdy
was it stat I got a position prevent GM
calm stack position equals dodge that's
it that's it okay position equals okay
what do we see here
first of all our parameters are not
great so I'm gonna do label equals
parameters you know text yes x equals
Ram there's y equals t PR okay I just
added that just so I could figure out
what what these are so we can see our
highest TP RA is five five nearest
neighbors using you user based
collaborative filtering user base Kahler
filtering appears to be the superior way
to do it
i BCF kind of stays at this point no
matter what although as we increase it
to 25 it seems to increase prom it's a
predictive power but five looks like the
sweet spot so we're gonna do five okay
so we're gonna say use five nearest
neighbors dope okay so we're gonna make
our final model we'll just we'll just
grab this up and we'll say prime equals
list nearest neighbors equals five okay
and then we can say was it oops
we can evaluate our model I've had isn't
it evaluate you v CF model method I was
I gotta read it again okay
okay I figured out how to make the final
model I was actually using the wrong
function one of the biggest problems I
guess recommender lab is a lot of their
functions are really unintuitive with
their naming conventions but is that you
create the final model I got to change
the nearest neighbor thing you just use
you're creating a recommender object or
actually a recommendation engine object
so if we look at our our final model we
created a UV CF model learned for it
using 85 users so since we finally did
our toon search our grid search for the
best tuning parameters for our nearest
neighbors and the best type of model we
can actually evaluate evaluate the model
so we're gonna say predict predict we're
gonna give it using our UV CF final
model we're gonna predict our our kind
of holdout set so we use our training
schema and we say we're gonna predict
we're gonna give it um then known data
or like four out of the five songs and
have it predict actually I'm gonna just
say I type equals top and list just to
make sure so um predictions predictions
and then we can calculate the actual
accuracy with um calc prediction
accuracy get data training schema and
this is actually the unknown songs that
were trying to predict with predictions
and we gave it all but one so equals
given all but one was it give your
predictions what's going on here oh I
think I got an idea predictions goes
right there given just right there there
you go so our TBR is nine percent
fine that's kind of what we're expecting
with our above graph so lastly we're
gonna actually create our final model
again but this time we'll call it the
wreck engine recommender get and instead
of using get data will use our rap
matrix or binary ratings matrix from our
that was kind of a source for actual
schema and we'll say our method is you
VCF parameter is list of his neighbor
with five nearest neighbors and boom we
created our recommendation engine
so let's actually use our recommendation
engine um I actually we originally used
all the polling data from it so was two
polls
select title distinct and then arranged
oops arranged by I don't okay so I'm
gonna actually do my song so I'm gonna
pull and I'm gonna say SCR detect a
Ciara detect detect and we'll say artist
and the pattern will be Kanye kind o is
it not artists it's yes artists
stringing artists calling it o filter
okay so Kanye I'm gonna say I like I'm
also say odd distinct title I'm gonna
say I like let's see here all say I all
the lights so I'm gonna say for mine
filter title is in oops
so I'm say filter all the songs are in
these these things so all the lights is
one just make sure it's I tapped in
right yep and then I'll say I like I
like I'll say all I can strap her you
know I really don't like okay I guess
transfer ever is in there
what else do I like I'll do you can
Drake Kendrick Lamar I'll be just kind
of a huge Kendrick Lamar fan so I'm
gonna I'm gonna stare an arranged title
I'm gonna say I like all right that's a
good song I like I like that song I'm
not gonna say it cuz this is a family
show even though I'm not sure if you're
like a little kid you're while you're
watching this I'm gonna do mad City
because I like that song too what else
do I so I have one two three four and
then I'll do I'll do one more I'll say
uh let's let's figure out what's what
else well those songs do what would I
like oh let's do it a Tupac song Tupac
so I'm gonna say I like changes too
that's that's another song like boom so
that's my order I'm gonna also now - are
buying polls select title just stinked
okay so now we have all of it and we're
say count title sort you count title
count count title and then we'll say
mutate N equals n minus one so now what
it's doing is basically convert all we
have our order and they're in the in the
in the product matrix and all orders
that are actually all values are
actually one are the things that I
wanted into my my top five list cool so
then we just do a generic hit it wider
name is from you know the same thing
values from equals and you fill the list
N equals zero right so now we have it if
we notice we should have where changes
we're just changes it changes as a one
write a stock matrix as
binary rating matrix and I'll say Andrew
songs lastly we're gonna just do the
predict wreck engine and we'll say
Andrew songs right and we'll say as dot
data frame oops
Oh AZ dot list right oh hi table
Oh how do i I think adds and then I do
that area as list and it as a data frame
boom so they're real it actually
predicted
I don't n ten songs I guess I thought I
so he said it's five that's fine so it
predicted ten songs that they think that
I might like okay so let's see if that
makes any sense so it says I actually
have heard you up I wrote like that song
and they do like Barack yell so the
engine does work this this is not
conclusive I don't miss evidence at all
but to me it does kind of make sense it
is recommending things that are pretty
relevant to me but you also can tell
that oh it's also not recommending a lot
of accurate information but it is
recommending a deist amount of
information and if you think about it
for the given data that was it for what
it was given it was only using 107 users
it didn't recommend always one useful
song that I think I would like so yeah
so this is basically how to make a
recommendation engine using recommender
lab it's pretty easy a lot of the the
functions are pretty um kind of unclear
however there's a nice vignette on their
site or the repo so it's pretty easy to
train up a recommendation engine pretty
fast and the pipeline is pretty
straightforward so I'll see you guys
next week and yeah tiding on